Fight Tough Headache and Migraine Pain two ways. Introducing new Advil Plus Acetaminophen. It combines two of the most trusted pain-fighting ingredients into one convenient tablet. Ibuprofen targets pain at the source, and Acetaminophen blocks pain signals, providing fast, effective pain relief for up to eight hours. Conquer headaches fast with the dual-action pain-fighting relief of new Advil Plus Acetaminophen, now available across Canada. Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents.
以两种方式对抗严重的头痛和偏头痛。隆重推出全新的Advil Plus Acetaminophen。它将两种最值得信赖的止痛成分结合在一片方便的药片中。布洛芬从源头靶向疼痛，而对乙酰氨基酚则阻断疼痛信号，提供长达八小时的快速、有效的止痛效果。用全新Advil Plus Acetaminophen的双重止痛功效快速战胜头痛，现已在加拿大各地上市。我们的剧集涉及严重且往往令人痛苦的事件。
If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. I revealed myself to those who did not ask for me. I was found by those who did not seek me. To a nation that did not call on my name, I said, Here am I, here am I. All day long I have held out my hands to an obstinate people who walk in ways not good,
如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您应用程序上或我们网站上本剧集的节目说明。我向那些没有询问我的人显现。我被那些没有寻找我的人找到了。对于一个没有呼求我名的人，我说，我在这里，我在这里。我整天向一个顽固的民族伸出双手，他们走在不好的道路上，
pursuing their own imaginations. At the age of ten, John Alan Chow stumbled across a copy of Robinson Crusoe in his father's study. The classic novel tells of a sailor shipwrecked on a deserted island. Captivated by the tale, John told his dad he wanted to live on a tropical island one day. Born in Alabama in 1991, John Chow spent most of his childhood in Vancouver, Washington. It was in the wilderness around his home where John developed a lifelong passion for the outdoors. As he got older, this love of nature morphed into something deeper. He saw it as a means to connect more fully with God.
追求他们自己的想象。十岁那年，约翰·艾伦·周（John Alan Chow）在他父亲的书房里偶然发现了一本《鲁滨逊漂流记》。这部经典小说讲述了一名水手在荒岛上遇难的故事。约翰被这个故事迷住了，他告诉父亲，他有一天想住在热带岛屿上。约翰·周于1991年出生在阿拉巴马州，童年的大部分时间是在华盛顿州的温哥华度过的。正是在他家周围的荒野中，约翰培养了对户外活动终生的热爱。随着年龄的增长，这种对大自然的热爱演变成了一些更深层的东西。他将其视为与上帝更充分地建立联系的一种方式。
John was raised as an evangelical Christian and faith played a critical role in his life. As he devoured Christian literature and stories, John found himself attracted to one facet of the religion in particular. Missionaries Mission work has been a part of Christianity since its inception, verses in the Gospel of Matthew quote Jesus Christ as telling his apostles to make disciples of all nations. These passages are known as the Great Commission and have led some Christians to believe they must save souls through conversion. As a teenager, John Chow encountered stories from the 19th and 20th centuries about famous missionaries who had converted people in Africa and South America.
约翰是在福音派基督教环境中长大的，信仰在他的生活中发挥了关键作用。随着他如饥似渴地阅读基督教文学和故事，约翰发现自己特别被宗教的一个方面所吸引。传教士。传教工作自基督教诞生以来就是其一部分，《马太福音》中的经文引用耶稣基督的话，告诉他的使徒们要使万民作他的门徒。这些段落被称为“大使命”，并导致一些基督徒相信他们必须通过皈依来拯救灵魂。十几岁时，约翰·周接触到了19世纪和20世纪关于在非洲和南美洲传教并使人们皈依的著名传教士的故事。
In an article published by Outside Magazine, journalist Alex Perry describes how John felt a particular affinity to American missionary Jim Elliott. Elliott's mission failed, however, when he was killed by an isolated Ecuadorian tribe. In 2008, John experienced his first taste of missionary life when he travelled to Mexico to help build an orphanage. The trip was a success. It inspired John. Mission work was the perfect path for him. John returned from Mexico curious about other places where he might complete a mission. He turned to the Joshua Project. Based in Colorado Springs, the Joshua Project is a Christian organization that collects information on ethnic groups around the world to provide data for missionaries. Visitors to the Joshua Project website can scroll through its databases of Unreached Peoples, the organization's term for non-Christian cultures. Users can search by language, country or religion to find more than 6,000 societies that are deemed in need of saving.
在《户外》杂志发表的一篇文章中，记者亚历克斯·佩里（Alex Perry）描述了约翰如何对美国传教士吉姆·埃利奥特（Jim Elliott）产生了一种特殊的亲近感。然而，埃利奥特的传教任务失败了，因为他被一个与世隔绝的厄瓜多尔部落杀害。2008年，约翰在前往墨西哥帮助建立孤儿院时，第一次体验了传教士的生活。这次旅行很成功。它激励了约翰。传教工作对他来说是完美的道路。约翰从墨西哥回来后，对其他他可能完成传教任务的地方感到好奇。他转向了“约书亚计划”（Joshua Project）。“约书亚计划”总部位于科罗拉多斯普林斯，是一个基督教组织，收集世界各地族群的信息，为传教士提供数据。“约书亚计划”网站的访问者可以滚动浏览其“未得之民”数据库，这是该组织对非基督教文化的称呼。用户可以按语言、国家或宗教进行搜索，以找到超过6,000个被认为需要拯救的社会。
John didn't want to go to a destination where others had already been. He wanted to reach people far away in the kind of remote locations he'd only ever read about. Clicking through the Joshua Project website, John discovered a page that caught his eye. It showed a tiny, blurry photo taken from the safety of a boat. It showed a small group of people gathered on a beach's shoreline, naked except for some loincloths. The entry was titled, Sentinelese in India. In the late 1870s, British naval officer Maurice Portman sailed through the Bay of Bengal, 1,370 kilometres east of India's mainland. Around him were the Andaman Islands, an archipelago of over 800 separate islands characterised by white sand beaches, lush rainforests, crystal clear lagoons and colourful coral reefs. Portman had been made officer-in-charge of the Andamanese. For the next 20 years, he travelled from island to island to, quote, civilise the native peoples, often times using force. In January 1880, Portman arrived on an island known as North Sentinel, a forested landmass roughly the size of Manhattan.
约翰不想去别人已经去过的地方。他想去他只在书本上读到过的那种偏远地区，接触那里的人们。在点击浏览“约书亚计划”网站时，约翰发现了一个吸引他眼球的页面。它展示了一张从船上安全位置拍摄的模糊小照片。照片显示一小群人聚集在海滩的岸边，除了几块缠腰布外，赤身裸体。条目标题为“印度的桑提内尔人”（Sentinelese in India）。19世纪70年代末，英国海军军官莫里斯·波特曼（Maurice Portman）航行穿过孟加拉湾，位于印度大陆以东1,370公里处。他周围是安达曼群岛，这是一个由800多个独立岛屿组成的群岛，以白沙滩、茂密的雨林、晶莹剔透的泻湖和色彩斑斓的珊瑚礁为特色。波特曼被任命为安达曼人的负责人。在接下来的20年里，他从一个岛屿旅行到另一个岛屿，去“教化”当地土著，往往使用武力。1880年1月，波特曼抵达了一个被称为北桑提内尔岛（North Sentinel）的岛屿，这是一片面积大约相当于曼哈顿的森林陆地。
After days of searching, Portman discovered the island's inhabitants, the Sentinelese people. Theorised to have migrated to the island from the African continent tens of thousands of years prior, the Sentinelese were a hunter-gatherer society that lived in makeshift hearts. The adult stood between 5'3 to 5'5 and their skin was described as, quote, shining black. The islanders fled from Portman and his group of armed men and local trackers. Undeterred, they continued their search of the island until they came across an older couple and their child. The man raised his bow, but was tackled and disarmed before being taken hostage along with his family. Portman also managed to capture three more children and took the sick-subducted Sentinelese back to his house in Port Blair, the region's capital on South Andaman Island. Not long after their arrival, the couple grew sick and died.
经过几天的搜寻，波特曼发现了岛上的居民——桑提内尔人。据推测，桑提内尔人在几万年前从非洲大陆迁徙到该岛，是一个生活在临时小屋里的狩猎采集社会。成年人身高在5英尺3英寸到5英尺5英寸之间，他们的皮肤被描述为“闪亮的黑色”。岛民从波特曼和他那群武装人员及当地追踪者面前逃走。他们没有被吓倒，继续搜寻该岛，直到遇到一对年长的夫妇和他们的孩子。那名男子举起弓，但在被劫持为人质及其家人之前被扑倒并解除了武装。波特曼还设法俘虏了另外三个孩子，并将这些生病的桑提内尔人带回了他在南安达曼岛首府布莱尔港的家中。他们到达后不久，这对夫妇就病倒并去世了。
Realising their illness was likely due to their contact with the outside world, Portman quickly sent the children back to North Sentinel Island along with an abundance of gifts. He didn't want to ruin his chances at making connections with the community. Portman later wrote about the incident, noting, This expedition was not a success. We cannot be said to have done anything more than increase their general terror of and hostility to all comers. After Maurice Portman's ill-fated trip, he kept trying to go back to North Sentinel, but he never established a relationship with the island's inhabitants. Many attribute his inhumane and fatal actions as to why the Sentinelese remained famously wary of outsiders to this day. Throughout the years, many others have attempted to reach out to the small population, but have been met with hostilities.
意识到他们的疾病很可能是由于与外界接触所致，波特曼迅速将孩子们连同大量礼物送回了北桑提内尔岛。他不想破坏自己与该社区建立联系的机会。波特曼后来在写到这件事时指出：“这次探险并不成功。我们不能说我们所做的不仅仅是增加了他们对所有来访者的普遍恐惧和敌意。”在莫里斯·波特曼那次不幸的旅行之后，他一直试图回到北桑提内尔，但他从未与岛上的居民建立起关系。许多人将他这种不人道和致命的行为归咎为桑提内尔人至今仍对外界保持警惕的原因。多年来，许多其他人也试图接触这一小群人口，但都遭到了敌意。
The Sentinelese have made it clear that they desire isolation above all else. Attempts at settlement in the 18th century devastated the five indigenous communities that resided on several of the Andaman Islands. Foreign infectious diseases and the introduction of drugs and alcohol by invaders decimated the native peoples. One tribe became extinct. Only one group managed to resist outsiders, the Sentinelese, considered the most secluded tribe in the world. It's believed that their population currently ranges between 100 and 150. The Indian government has made it illegal for anyone to visit North Sentinel Island or even go within three miles of it, both for the protection of the highly vulnerable residents and that of any would-be visitors. The Joshua Project's write-up about the Sentinelese explained that their language was unwritten and had no biblical resources.
桑提内尔人已经明确表示，他们最渴望的是与世隔绝。18世纪的定居尝试摧毁了居住在安达曼群岛上几个岛屿的五个土著社区。外来的传染病以及入侵者引入的毒品和酒精使当地土著人口锐减。一个部落灭绝了。只有一个群体成功抵御了外来者，那就是桑提内尔人，他们被认为是世界上最与世隔绝的部落。据信，他们目前的人口在100到150人之间。印度政府已将任何人访问北桑提内尔岛，甚至进入其三英里范围内定为非法，这既是为了保护这些高度脆弱的居民，也是为了保护任何潜在的访客。“约书亚计划”关于桑提内尔人的文章解释说，他们的语言没有文字，也没有圣经资源。
It did note that visiting the island was banned, but concluded, Sentinelese people need to know that the creator God exists and that he loves them and paid the price for their sins. As soon as 17-year-old John Chow read about the Sentinelese in 2009, he felt certain of one thing. He had discovered his destiny. North Sentinel was the last frontier he'd dreamed of since childhood, a remote, unexplored island with residents who needed to hear Christ's message, and it had been left near untouched for him alone to discover and save. John began to speak of the Sentinelese often and openly.
它确实提到访问该岛是被禁止的，但总结道：“桑提内尔人需要知道创造主上帝的存在，他爱他们，并为他们的罪付出了代价。”17岁的约翰·周在2009年读到关于桑提内尔人的文章后，他确信了一件事。他发现了自己的命运。北桑提内尔是他自童年以来一直梦想的最后边疆，一个偏远、未被探索的岛屿，那里的居民需要听到基督的信息，而且它几乎未被触动，留给他一个人去发现和拯救。约翰开始经常且公开地谈论桑提内尔人。
One day, his father, Patrick, overheard John talking about the island with some friends. John knew his plan was dangerous, but at the same time, the risk made it all the more important. Patrick felt nothing but dismay. This didn't sound like a plan that would work out well for his son. Between 2012 and 2015, John flew to Cape Town for a university mission trip, went to Kurdistan with the Christian soccer charity, and took an evangelical tour of Israel. Then, in October 2015, he finally made his way to India. Over the next few years, John would travel to the Andamans a total of four times. As he spent more time there, he became increasingly convinced of going to North Sentinel.
有一天，他的父亲帕特里克（Patrick）无意中听到约翰和一些朋友谈论这个岛屿。约翰知道他的计划很危险，但与此同时，这种风险使它变得更加重要。帕特里克感到无比沮丧。这听起来不像是一个对他儿子有好处的计划。2012年至2015年间，约翰飞往开普敦参加大学传教之旅，与基督教足球慈善机构去了库尔德斯坦，并参加了以色列的福音派巡回活动。然后，在2015年10月，他终于前往印度。在接下来的几年里，约翰总共四次前往安达曼群岛。随着他在那里待的时间越来越长，他越来越确信要前往北桑提内尔。
He noticed a number of signs that pointed to him being the only person who could convert the Sentinelese. His Chinese heritage helped him blend in with the local fishermen, so he'd be better placed to sneak out to the island when the time finally came. And, like the Sentinelese, John was on the smaller side at 5'6 and 130 pounds. This would make him appear less threatening to the tribe. In the summer of 2017, John attended a two-month course on translating the Bible into new languages at the Canadian Institute of Linguistics. His dream was to learn Sentinelese, a language known by no one except the islanders, and interpret the Bible for them. If the tribe accepted him, John hoped to stay with them for many years, maybe even forever.
他注意到一些迹象表明他是唯一能使桑提内尔人皈依的人。他的华裔血统帮助他融入当地渔民，因此当最终时机到来时，他将处于更有利的位置潜入该岛。而且，像桑提内尔人一样，约翰身材较小，身高5英尺6英寸，体重130磅。这会使他在部落面前看起来不那么具有威胁性。2017年夏天，约翰在加拿大语言学院参加了一个为期两个月的将圣经翻译成新语言的课程。他的梦想是学习桑提内尔语——一种除了岛民之外无人知晓的语言，并为他们翻译圣经。如果部落接受他，约翰希望与他们住上许多年，甚至永远住下去。
In October 2017, he flew to Missouri to participate in a rigorous three-week-long boot camp with missionary organization All Nations. The program was intended to teach John how to interact with foreigners who had little or no understanding of Christianity. In one instance, John was blindfolded and driven to an isolated location. He had to walk until he came across a pretend village. Members of All Nations dressed in clothes from thrift stores and carried spears in an effort to look like remote tribespeople. They pretended they couldn't understand what John was saying and took on hostile postures. John thrived during his training. The organizers were very impressed by him. John avoided romantic relationships so he'd have fewer ties to home.
2017年10月，他飞往密苏里州，参加了传教组织“万国”（All Nations）为期三周的严格训练营。该项目旨在教导约翰如何与那些对基督教知之甚少或一无所知的外国人互动。有一次，约翰被蒙上眼睛，开车带到一个偏僻的地方。他必须步行，直到遇到一个假想的村庄。万国组织的成员穿着从旧货店买来的衣服，拿着长矛，试图看起来像偏远的部落民。他们假装听不懂约翰在说什么，并采取了敌对的姿态。约翰在训练中表现出色。组织者对他印象非常深刻。约翰避免了浪漫关系，这样他就与家乡的联系更少。
He got vaccinations for 13 infectious diseases. He stuck to a healthy diet and exercised regularly. Sometimes, he took his kayak out in choppy waters to practice what it might be like to row out to North Sentinel. Over the course of two years, he read more than 100 books on mission work and anthropology. He also sought advice from others who had completed missions with uncontacted peoples. According to GQ Magazine, John put together a 27-step plan outlining how he would undertake his mission. First, he'd win the Sentinelese over with gifts and would use drawings to communicate his desire to stay with them. Then, he'd learn the language and translate relatable stories from the Bible for them.
他接种了13种传染病的疫苗。他坚持健康饮食并定期锻炼。有时，他会带着皮划艇去波涛汹涌的水域练习划船前往北桑提内尔可能会是什么样子。在两年多的时间里，他阅读了100多本关于传教工作和人类学的书籍。他还向其他完成过与未接触部落传教任务的人寻求建议。据《GQ》杂志报道，约翰制定了一个27步的计划，概述了他将如何进行他的传教任务。首先，他会用礼物赢得桑提内尔人的好感，并会用图画来表达他想与他们住在一起的愿望。然后，他会学习语言，并为他们翻译圣经中相关的故事。
Once he forged good relationships with the tribe's leaders, the entire group would join the Christian faith. By fall of 2018, John Chow was finally ready. He booked a flight to Port Blair and landed on October 16. Days later, he caught a 10-hour ferry to the island of Little Andaman. It lay some distance south of North Sentinel and was home to the Yonge tribe, one of the other remaining Andamanese peoples. According to Outside Magazine, John hoped to convince some of them to accompany him to North Sentinel, but was unable to, for reasons unknown. On November 3, John travelled back to Port Blair. His mission was one he'd have to undertake alone. Perhaps it was better that way.
一旦他与部落领导人建立了良好的关系，整个群体就会加入基督教信仰。到2018年秋天，约翰·周终于准备好了。他预订了飞往布莱尔港的航班，并于10月16日降落。几天后，他搭乘了10小时的渡轮前往小安达曼岛。它位于北桑提内尔以南的一段距离处，是昂格部落（Yonge tribe）的家园，这是安达曼群岛其他剩余的土著民族之一。据《户外》杂志报道，约翰希望说服他们中的一些人陪他去北桑提内尔，但由于未知原因未能成功。11月3日，约翰回到了布莱尔港。他的传教任务是他必须独自完成的。也许这样更好。
The Sentinelese would be less threatened by one person than a group. John entered a self-imposed quarantine for the next 11 days. He gathered supplies, including pencils, tools, multivitamins, medicine, abdominal pad dressings, and dental forceps to remove arrows that might be shot at him. John also collected gifts that he would offer the islanders, safety pins, scissors, tweezers, fishing line, and hooks. One day, two friends of John's showed up. Both were evangelical Christians from America and were aware of his plan. John was excited when one of them shared good news. They had found some people who were willing to help him reach his goal. A crew of local fishermen had agreed to take John out to North Sentinel. They couldn't speak English, but they were Christians and were sympathetic to John's cause.
桑提内尔人对一个人的威胁感会比对一群人小。约翰进行了为期11天的自我隔离。他收集了补给品，包括铅笔、工具、多种维生素、药物、腹部敷料和用于取出可能射向他的箭的牙科镊子。约翰还收集了将提供给岛民的礼物：别针、剪刀、镊子、鱼线和鱼钩。有一天，约翰的两个朋友出现了。他们都是来自美国的福音派基督徒，并且知道他的计划。当其中一人分享好消息时，约翰很兴奋。他们找到了一些愿意帮助他实现目标的人。一群当地渔民同意带约翰去北桑提内尔。他们不会说英语，但他们是基督徒，并且同情约翰的事业。
Because they'd be taking a great risk by helping him, they wanted 25,000 rupees, the equivalent of US$360. John readily agreed. A plan was made for them to set sail for the island on the evening of Wednesday, November 14. Hours before they were due to leave, John scribbled an entry in his journal. He asked God for help and gave thanks for being shaped and moulded as Christ's ambassador. Sailing under cover of darkness, the crew was careful to avoid the Indian Coast Guard. As they approached North Sentinel, John spotted three large fires burning on its eastern shoreline. But lights from boats in the distance prompted the crew to head south to avoid being caught by authorities.
因为帮助他会冒很大的风险，他们想要25,000卢比，相当于360美元。约翰欣然同意。他们计划于11月14日星期三晚上启航前往该岛。在他们出发前几个小时，约翰在日记中潦草地写下了一段话。他祈求上帝的帮助，并感谢自己被塑造成基督的使者。在夜色的掩护下航行，船员们小心翼翼地避开印度海岸警卫队。当他们接近北桑提内尔时，约翰发现东海岸线上燃起了三堆大火。但远处船只的灯光促使船员们向南行驶，以避免被当局抓获。
They moored and waited for dawn to break. When he closed his eyes, John saw what he could only describe as a vision. Built across an island was a city skyline topped with the jagged spires. The scene was cast in a purple-coloured hue. John saw a meteorite fall to earth. He felt troubled and uneasy, but then the purple light and sharp spires faded. They were replaced with a pure white glow. John was no longer scared.
他们停泊并等待黎明破晓。当他闭上眼睛时，约翰看到了他只能描述为异象的东西。在岛屿上空矗立着一座城市天际线，顶部是锯齿状的尖顶。场景笼罩在紫色的色调中。约翰看到一颗陨石坠落到地球上。他感到困扰和不安，但随后紫色的光芒和尖锐的尖顶消失了。它们被纯白色的光芒所取代。约翰不再害怕了。
At 4.30am, the crew steered the boat into a cove on the west side of the island. A large hut crafted by the Sentinelese was visible on the shore. A few hours later, John began his approach. He loaded up a kayak with his gifts and personal documents, as well as two large fish that his crewmates had caught. John paddled towards the shore. As he drew closer, he heard women yell and cry out. He kept rowing. Two Sentinelese men suddenly appeared and ran towards him, both carrying bows and arrows.
凌晨4点30分，船员们将船驶入岛屿西侧的一个小海湾。岸上可以看到桑提内尔人建造的一个大棚屋。几个小时后，约翰开始了他的接近。他用皮划艇装载了他的礼物和个人文件，以及他的船员捕获的两条大鱼。约翰向岸边划去。当他靠近时，他听到女人们大喊大叫。他继续划船。两名桑提内尔男子突然出现并向他跑来，两人都带着弓箭。
John called out. My name is John. I love you, and Jesus loves you. Jesus Christ gave me authority to come to you. Here is some fish. The men ignored him and knocked arrows into their bows. John hastily threw one of the fish towards them, then the other, before paddling backwards to a safe distance. The Sentinelese men retrieved the fish. John decided to return to the boat for now. Hours later, John was ready for his second attempt.
约翰大声喊道：“我的名字是约翰。我爱你们，耶稣也爱你们。耶稣基督给了我来到你们这里的权威。这是给你们的一些鱼。”男人们无视他，将箭搭在弓上。约翰匆忙地将其中一条鱼扔向他们，然后是另一条，随后向后划到安全距离。桑提内尔男子取回了鱼。约翰决定暂时回到船上。几个小时后，约翰准备好了他的第二次尝试。
This time he paddled his kayak loaded up with more fish and gifts to the island's north shore. Once again, the Sentinelese shouted upon seeing the stranger. When six Sentinelese men called out words that John couldn't understand, he tried to mimic them in an effort to communicate. This caused the group to laugh. Then, two islanders dropped their weapons and steered a handmade canoe out to meet him. John delivered the fish and some presents from a distance. The encounter seemed to be going well. Then, a young woman and a child emerged from the dense forest and walked towards the sand, both aiming bows at him. John gestured that they should drop their weapons. They ignored him.
这一次，他划着装满更多鱼和礼物的皮划艇前往岛屿的北岸。桑提内尔人看到陌生人时再次大喊大叫。当六名桑提内尔男子喊出约翰听不懂的词语时，他试图模仿他们以进行交流。这引起了那群人的大笑。然后，两名岛民放下武器，划着一艘手工独木舟出来迎接他。约翰从远处递送了鱼和一些礼物。这次接触似乎进行得很顺利。然后，一名年轻女子和一个孩子从茂密的森林中走出来，走向沙滩，两人都用弓箭瞄准他。约翰示意他们应该放下武器。他们无视他。
By this time, the waves had picked up and John's kayak drifted towards some shallow coral behind him, blocking him in. Wondering if this was his moment of reckoning, John pulled out his waterproof Bible and recited verses from the Book of Genesis. One unarmed islander stood just inches away, so John handed him more gifts. When he got out of his kayak to show that he had two legs just as they did, the Sentinelese saw an opportunity and seized his vessel. John held his Bible in front of his chest, still speaking to the crowd. Then, the young boy who'd been aiming a bow released an arrow directly at him. It landed in the middle of John's Bible. He yanked the arrow from the book, threw it back towards the boy, then dove into the water. With his kayak gone, he had no choice but to swim back to the boat. Fit and strong, John was able to power through the water quite easily.
此时，海浪已经变大，约翰的皮划艇漂向他身后的一些浅珊瑚礁，挡住了他的去路。约翰想知道这是否是他清算的时刻，他拿出防水圣经，背诵了《创世记》中的经文。一名手无寸铁的岛民站在离他几英寸远的地方，所以约翰递给他更多的礼物。当他走出皮划艇以表明他像他们一样有两条腿时，桑提内尔人看到了机会并夺取了他的船只。约翰把圣经举在胸前，继续对人群说话。然后，那个一直瞄准他的小男孩直接向他射出了一支箭。它落在了约翰圣经的中间。他从书中拔出箭，把它扔回给男孩，然后跳进水里。皮划艇没了，他别无选择，只能游回船上。约翰身体强壮，能够相当轻松地在水中游动。
He breathed the sigh of relief when he finally reached the boat. When he checked his Bible, John saw that the arrow had pierced the Book of Isaiah, chapter 63 verse 5 to chapter 65 verse 2. In the Scripture, the prophet Isaiah predicts imminent judgment but eventual restoration for obstinate people. One section begins. I revealed myself to those who did not ask for me and goes on to encourage the reader to reach out to those who walk in ways not good in order to get them to commit to faith. John was shaken. He'd known that being shot at was a probable outcome of his attempts. It was well recorded that the Sentinelese pelted intruders with rocks, spears and arrows. But the experience had scared and upset John nonetheless.
当他最终到达船上时，他松了一口气。当他检查圣经时，约翰看到箭刺穿了《以赛亚书》第63章第5节到第65章第2节。在经文中，先知以赛亚预言了对顽固民族的迫在眉睫的审判，但最终会得到恢复。其中一段开头写道：“我向那些没有询问我的人显现”，并继续鼓励读者去接触那些走在不好的道路上的人，以使他们致力于信仰。约翰感到震惊。他知道被射击是他尝试的可能结果。有充分记录表明，桑提内尔人会用石头、长矛和箭攻击入侵者。但这次经历仍然让约翰感到害怕和不安。
Plus, when he lost his kayak, he had also lost everything it contained, including his passport and official documents. In his journal, John debated what to do. Would it be wiser to leave and let someone else continue? No, I don't think so. I'm stuck here anyway without a passport. It almost seems like certain death to stay here. Yet, there is evidential change in two encounters in a single day. John decided to rest on the boat overnight to regain his strength, then try again early the following morning. He was afraid of dying, but he was even more worried about who would take on the role of saving the Sentinelese if he gave up on his mission.
此外，当他失去皮划艇时，他也失去了里面的一切，包括他的护照和官方文件。在日记中，约翰讨论了该怎么做。离开并让别人继续会更明智吗？“不，我不这么认为。反正我没有护照被困在这里了。留在这里几乎肯定是死路一条。然而，在一天之内就有两次接触的证据性变化。”约翰决定在船上过夜休息以恢复体力，然后在第二天清晨再次尝试。他害怕死亡，但他更担心如果他放弃传教任务，谁会承担拯救桑提内尔人的角色。
As he watched the sunset, John began to cry. He knew it might be the last time he ever saw such a sight. He missed his family and friends. None of the fishermen could speak English, and John desperately wanted someone to talk to. The next morning, he woke early to write once more in his journal and penned some letters to his friends and family. A little after 6.20am, John stripped down to his underpants so he would more closely resemble the Naked Islanders. He got back in the water. Then, he began swimming in the direction of the hut he'd visited the previous day.
当他看着日落时，约翰开始哭泣。他知道这可能是他最后一次看到这样的景象。他想念他的家人和朋友。渔民中没有一个人会说英语，约翰非常渴望有人能和他说话。第二天早上，他早早醒来，再次在日记中写下了一些东西，并给他的朋友和家人写了一些信。早上6点20分过后，约翰脱得只剩下内裤，这样他看起来会更像赤身裸体的岛民。他回到水里。然后，他开始向他前一天访问过的棚屋方向游去。
That day, the five fishermen who'd taken John out to North Sentinel remained at sea, completing their usual work schedule. Afterwards, they spent another night out on the boat. Then, the following day, they headed back to North Sentinel to check on John. They strained their eyes as they steered around the perimeter of the island. Then, they noticed something. A few of the Sentinelese were using rope to drag something across the sand. It was a human corpse, with the rope wrapped around the neck. Nearby, was a recently dug grave.
那天，带约翰去北桑提内尔的五名渔民留在海上，完成了他们通常的工作计划。之后，他们在船上又过了一夜。然后，第二天，他们回到北桑提内尔查看约翰的情况。当他们绕着岛屿周边行驶时，他们瞪大了眼睛。然后，他们注意到了什么。几个桑提内尔人正在用绳子拖着沙滩上的东西。那是一具人类尸体，绳子缠在脖子上。附近有一个刚挖好的坟墓。
The fishermen recognized the body instantly. It was John Chow. They watched as the Sentinelese dropped John into the grave and buried him. The fishermen rushed back to Port Blair. Word soon got back to John's mother, Linda. A missing person's report was immediately issued. The Andaman's director of police had North Sentinel Island scanned from the sky and water, but none of the officers could see any sign of John.
渔民们立刻认出了那具尸体。那是约翰·周。他们看着桑提内尔人把约翰扔进坟墓并埋葬了他。渔民们匆忙赶回布莱尔港。消息很快传到了约翰的母亲琳达（Linda）那里。失踪人员报告立即发出。安达曼警察局长对北桑提内尔岛进行了空中和水上扫描，但没有一名警官能看到约翰的任何踪迹。
On November 21, police issued a press release titled, Urgent, Death of US National. It detailed how 26-year-old John Alan Chow had been killed during a misplaced adventure, trying to interact with uncontacted peoples in a highly restricted area. The bizarre story caught the attention of the world's media. Many criticized John's decision to attempt a mission in the area. By doing so, he had not only broken the law, but shown extreme disregard for the survival of the Sentinelese and their culture.
11月21日，警方发布了一份题为“紧急，美国公民死亡”的新闻稿。它详细说明了26岁的约翰·艾伦·周是如何在一次错误的冒险中被杀的，他试图与高度限制区域内未接触的部落进行互动。这个离奇的故事引起了世界媒体的关注。许多人批评约翰试图在该地区进行传教的决定。通过这样做，他不仅触犯了法律，而且对桑提内尔人的生存及其文化表现出了极大的漠视。
Some expressed regret that John had been killed, while also pointing out that his actions had been stupid at best. Others were more scathing, describing John as dumb with a misguided sense of moral superiority. The director of Survival International, a group that advocates for indigenous rights, issued a statement that read, the Sentinelese have shown again and again that they want to be left alone and their wishes should be respected. I hope this tragedy acts as a wake-up call to the Indian authorities to avert another disaster
一些人对约翰被杀表示遗憾，同时也指出他的行为充其量是愚蠢的。其他人则更加尖刻，将约翰描述为“愚蠢”，并带有误导性的道德优越感。倡导土著权利的组织“国际生存”（Survival International）的主任发表了一份声明，写道：“桑提内尔人一次又一次地表明他们希望被单独留下，他们的意愿应该得到尊重。我希望这场悲剧能成为印度当局的警钟，以避免另一场灾难，
and properly protect the lands of both the Sentinelese and the other Andaman tribes from further invaders. All nations, the missionary organization that John had trained with, also released a statement. It concluded, Throughout church history, the privilege of sharing the gospel has often involved great cost. We pray that John's sacrificial efforts will bear eternal fruit in due season. Indian law enforcement was faced with the difficult question of what to do in the wake of John's death. In his final letter to his family, John had acknowledged the likelihood that he could die and requested that his body not be retrieved.
并适当地保护桑提内尔人和其他安达曼部落的土地免受进一步的入侵者侵害。”约翰曾接受过训练的传教组织“万国”也发表了一份声明。它总结道：“在教会历史上，分享福音的特权往往涉及巨大的代价。我们祈祷约翰的牺牲努力将在适当的时候结出永恒的果实。”印度执法部门面临着在约翰死后该怎么做的难题。在他给家人的最后一封信中，约翰承认了他可能会死的可能性，并要求不要找回他的尸体。
The police agreed with this. Attempting to do so would be too dangerous, both for their officials and the Sentinelese. The killing of John Chow raised a unique ethical question. He was, by definition, murdered. However, those responsible for his death were extremely isolated from modern society and oblivious to the laws that govern it. The process of accessing the island to formally charge inhabitants was yet another risky proposition, both for law enforcement and the islanders.
警方同意了这一点。尝试这样做太危险了，无论是对他们的官员还是对桑提内尔人来说。约翰·周的被杀提出了一个独特的伦理问题。根据定义，他是被谋杀的。然而，那些对他死亡负责的人与现代社会极其隔绝，对管理现代社会的法律一无所知。进入该岛正式起诉居民的过程对于执法部门和岛民来说都是另一个冒险的提议。
Though it was considered initially. This notion was quickly put to rest when the US government announced that it had not asked the Indian government to pursue any sort of sanctions against the tribe. Nor would they do so themselves. Most members of the public believed the blame for John Chow's murder lay entirely at his own feet. That he had invited the aggression of the tribe, as it was well known that they violently resisted outsiders. Unlike the Sentinelese, those who'd taken John to meet with his killers could be pursued legally. The five fishermen had broken the law by abetting John's trip to the island.
虽然最初考虑过，但当美国政府宣布没有要求印度政府对该部落采取任何形式的制裁时，这一想法很快就被搁置了。他们自己也不会这样做。大多数公众认为约翰·周被谋杀的责任完全在于他自己。他招致了部落的攻击，因为众所周知，他们会暴力抵御外来者。与桑提内尔人不同，那些带约翰去见凶手的人可以在法律上受到追究。这五名渔民因教唆约翰前往该岛而触犯了法律。
They were all arrested, as was a local tour guide and the friend John stayed with in Port Blair. The wife of one of the fishermen told The New York Times, I am frustrated hearing John's name. He has filled my family with sorrow for our whole life. The Chow family asked for the release of the arrested individuals as they knew such a development would have deeply upset John. The arrestees were soon freed on bail. As of the release of this episode, there has been no news as to how prosecution is proceeding. In July 2020, news website Op India reported that Andaman police were planning to send a summons letter to John Chow's two American friends,
他们都被逮捕了，当地的一名导游和约翰在布莱尔港住的朋友也被逮捕了。其中一名渔民的妻子告诉《纽约时报》：“听到约翰的名字我很沮丧。他让我们全家一生都充满了悲伤。”周家要求释放被捕人员，因为他们知道这样的发展会深深地困扰约翰。被捕者很快被保释。截至本剧集发布时，还没有关于起诉如何进行的消息。2020年7月，新闻网站Op India报道称，安达曼警方计划向约翰·周的两名美国朋友发出传票，
who visited Port Blair in the days before his death. They had put him in touch with the fishermen. Investigators had hinted that they believed John had been brainwashed into completing his mission. Although there are many records showing it had been his personal passion project for many years. John's father Patrick has been the most outspoken member of the family, openly blaming what he calls an extreme brand of Christianity for his son's death. In emails he exchanged with a journalist from The Guardian, Patrick described religion as the opium of the masses, and said John's fixation with faith had been a longstanding issue between the two of them. The Chows have left John's Instagram account online as a tribute to his life.
他们在约翰死前几天访问了布莱尔港。他们让他与渔民取得了联系。调查人员暗示，他们认为约翰是被洗脑去完成他的传教任务的。尽管有许多记录显示这是他多年来的个人热情项目。约翰的父亲帕特里克是家里最直言不讳的成员，公开指责他所说的“极端基督教”导致了他儿子的死亡。在与《卫报》记者交换的电子邮件中，帕特里克将宗教描述为“人民的鸦片”，并表示约翰对信仰的执着是他们两人之间长期存在的问题。周家保留了约翰的Instagram账户，作为对他生命的纪念。
Comments are now restricted, but all of John's photos from his many adventures remain visible. The final and most recent picture is one his family uploaded several days after his death. It features a photograph of John beaming in front of a rushing river with mountains in the distance. It is accompanied by the caption, Words cannot express the sadness we have experienced. He was a beloved son, brother, uncle, and best friend to us. He loved God, life, helping those in need, and had nothing but love for the Sentinelese people. We forgive those reportedly responsible for his death.
评论现在受到限制，但约翰所有冒险经历的照片仍然可见。最后一张也是最近的一张照片是他家人在他死后几天上传的。照片中，约翰在奔腾的河流前笑容满面，远处是群山。配文是：“言语无法表达我们所经历的悲伤。他是我们深爱的儿子、兄弟、叔叔和最好的朋友。他爱上帝，爱生活，爱帮助有需要的人，对桑提内尔人只有爱。我们原谅那些据称对他死亡负责的人。”
He ventured out on his own free will. John Chow remains buried on North Sentinel Island. In his final letter to his friends and family penned November 16, 2018, he wrote, You guys might think I'm crazy in all this, but I think it's worth it to declare Jesus to these people. This is not a pointless thing. The eternal lives of this tribe are at hand and I can't wait to see them around the throne of God worshipping in their language as Revelation chapter 7 verses 9 to 10 states. I love you all and I pray none of you love anything in this world more than Jesus Christ. Written from the Cove on the southwest ish of North Sentinel Island.
他是出于自己的自由意志去冒险的。约翰·周仍然被埋葬在北桑提内尔岛。在他于2018年11月16日写给朋友和家人的最后一封信中，他写道：“你们可能认为我疯了，但我认为向这些人宣告耶稣是值得的。这不是一件毫无意义的事情。这个部落的永恒生命就在眼前，我迫不及待地想看到他们在上帝的宝座周围用他们的语言敬拜，正如《启示录》第7章第9至10节所说的那样。我爱你们所有人，我祈祷你们中没有人比爱耶稣基督更爱这个世界上的任何东西。”写于北桑提内尔岛西南侧的海湾。
Copyright © 2020 North Sentinel There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
版权所有 © 2020 North Sentinel。本剧集尚无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。